il donne des images à la guerre l'hôte
de proue des pollens vologe dernier qu
il n ya que quand on écoute quelqu'un
parler et que ça crée des images dans
notre cerveau forcément on adhère
beaucoup plus aux propos que si c'était
un espèce de vocabulaire bureaucratique
diplomate que les tous les gens ne
saisissent pas forcément
[Musique]
bio
coop einstein azad or she did now ce qui
frappe tout de suite chez vladimir
zelensky c'est quasiment tout de suite
le non verbal c'est la manière qu'il a
eu quasiment dès le départ de s'habiller
avec ce tee shirt en vert kaki il est
apparu finalement une seule fois avec un
costume c'était le 24 février et des
lendemains on voit qu'il a lâché le
costume pour enfiler on va dire son
uniforme quelque part qu'à qui est donc
là on voit vraiment à travers un détail
comme ça dès le début cet objectif de
montrer qu'il est acculé sur le terrain
en fait se bat véritablement aux côtés
de ses concitoyens et aussi de garder le
moral le moral des troupes en fait il se
pose à la fois en présidant en chef de
guerre tout en veillant à garder une
vraie proximité avec les succès de rang
pour
l'asmo l'égide de jean baratte aussi
vous fait courir le monde sait pourquoi
et d'évoquer
la
suite
ce
qui change c'est
qu'il a quelque chose qui est qui est
primordial chez lui c'est qu'il maîtrise
très bien les codes de la mise en scène
c'est encore une fois l'expérience de
l'acteur qui parle dans son discours au
parlement et regarde véritablement bien
l'oeil de la caméra pour s'assurer qui
s'adresse véritablement aux dirigeants
il sait bien placer sa voix il s'est
assez bien aussi se mouvoir on va dire
dans l'espace quand il est derrière le
pupitre il a quand même une même en
étant petit il a une vraie stature
ce qui est intéressant dans ce procès
qui commence en fait parce qu'on appelle
une exorde c'est vraiment le début du
discours une exemple par la gravité en
disant je suis très content de voir que
nous avons réussi à unifier l'europe
mais je pensais pas que ce serait le
prix à payer est là en fait en une
phrase vous avez quasiment tout le
résumé du discours qui la suivent alors
évidemment la situation dans laquelle se
trouve l'ukraine mais aussi son désir de
rejoindre l'union européenne et donc on
sait très bien dès le départ finalement
où est ce qu'on va et quels sont les
enjeux de l'allocution est ce qu'on
remarque juste après
quasiment la phrase qui suit c'est qu'il
nous parle face caméra qu'il est sans
note d'ailleurs il montre ses notes pour
montrer qu'il ne les utilise pas on a un
petit effet comme ça pour dire
finalement bas
aujourd'hui le temps des beaux discours
sur du papier le temps où on prend on
prend le temps justement de nos réécrire
etc c'est fini on est en temps de guerre
et là on est dans une réalité qui a
passé ce cas donc le message c'est
vraiment terminé les discours policé moi
je suis saoul et mon peuple et sous les
bombes et l'heure est à l'action yahoo
tout
comme
[Musique]
steve quelques poteries de choper le
morty outils
il connaît pas que les codes des réseaux
sociaux ils mettraient aussi ceux des
punchline des formules quand il dit à
joe biden qui lui propose de l'exfiltrer
d'ukraine j'ai besoin de munitions j'ai
pas besoin d'un taxi on est sur une
formule qui à la fois très très courte
qui est très efficace parce qu'elle
reste pas facilement mémoire et qui donc
dispose d'une énorme viralité et ça je
pense vont le devenir zelensky en a bien
conscience cette nécessité en fait
d'efficacité dans ses prises de parole
dans une guerre forcément là les
occasions de prendre la parole en tout
cas sur la longueur sont assez rares
donc il faut aller tout de suite aux
points importants j'ai un peu
l'impression si on devait faire un
parallèle avec des leaders occidentaux
qu'on est sur un mélange un peu entre
churchill et reagan voulait rona du
régal sur la forme avec ce côté acteurs
ce côté qui maîtrise les codes ce regard
voilà mise en scène etc et puis on a un
côté peut-être plus sur le fond qui qui
fait penser à churchill avec cette idée
que nous nous rendrons jamais et
d'ailleurs il a s'est plusieurs fois il
rend il a rendu hommage à son peuple
notamment pendant le discours qu'il a
faits au parlement en disant je suis
persuadé que nous gagnerons personne ne
nous ne nous brisera nous sommes forts
nous sommes tus craignent un ya toujours
vraiment à coeur de stimuler son peuple
et ça ça fait quand même beau discours
de churchill qui l'avait fait en juin 40
devant la chambre des communes où ils
avaient essayé galvanisé justement le
peuple britannique mais aussi le peuple
français en l'appelant à la résistance
que hélène ce qui fait et c'est aussi un
petit peu de fer avec le peuple russe et
aussi en appelant au nouveau monde pour
venir sauver l'ancien donc vous voyez
que sur deux conflits qui sont quand
même séparés de plusieurs dizaines
d'années on retrouve finalement des
similarités hommage au niveau du show au
niveau du message joe louis du rhône et
de
l'état qui je mets mon fils a mis ses
bases
d'abord rejeté en masse d'où je peaufine
au bras c'est ludovic des listes à
gauche hippolyte big three to the lead
est vite jong il n'a acheté dans cette
adresse il durcit vraiment le ton
vis-à-vis des leaders occidentaux en
juin sur un sur un nouveau levier on
voit que la voix se fait plus sèche le
ton vraiment se durcit et il dit
nous sommes des humains donc c'est votre
devoir humanitaire de nous protéger vous
pouvez le faire et si vous ne le fait
pas alors il n'y a qu'une conclusion si
vous aussi vous voulez nous voir mourir
et là on voit qu'on a un levier si vous
voulez émotionnel énorme qui est qui est
activée parce que non seulement il
s'adresse aux dirigeants mais bien
évidemment il s'adresse aussi à
l'opinion publique il a préféré donc
jouer sur des leviers de pathos dès le
départ que sur des leviers plus
rationnelle par exemple plutôt que de
parler de war internationale ou du
mémorandum de budapest il choisit de
parler du fait que sa famille a combattu
dans l'armée soviétique et il sait qu'il
doit sortir cette carte quelque part
parce que ils savaient qu'un outil qui
est très très puissant face qui est
celui la propagande russe et qui brandit
l'idée qu'il est nécessaire de des nazis
fier l'ukraine donc ça l'amène à une
question rhétorique qui est d'ailleurs
un un procédé qu'il utilise assez
régulièrement en disant mais comment une
nation pour être qualifiés de nazis
alors qu'elle a sacrifié 8 millions de
vies pour éradiquer le nazisme comment
moi je pourrais être nazi alors que mon
grand père a combattu dans l'infanterie
soviétique chute autres nash et
jusqu'aux tout rond et diana sospiri
sotchi
total
cela vaut nations unies
[Musique]